all right we know we're well into
November but we're still talking about
all of this year's epic celebrity
Halloween costume Heidi Klum anyone that
worms uh still not over costume of
descent it's amazing uh now one of the
amazing costumes that comes to mind
comes from Harry Styles who traded his
bold outfits for a leather jacket kind
of like this one and slicked back hair
as he channeled Danny zuka from Greece
for his annual Harry ween concert yes
but that's not all Harry didn't just
dress the part of the character he also
sang a perfect rendition of hopelessly
devoted to you while the photo of Olivia
Newton-John who passed away in August
with shown on screen take a look
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
not an easy song that is to do no and I
have to tell you I was being little
judgy Sally over here that's not even a
saying uh and I was like
that's okay and then when you get those
shoes
Sally I really messed that up
um but then when he hit those notes you
have to go low and then go so high he
gave it out I'm impressed I would love
to sing that in karaoke and I think
that's what we should do you want me to
do is this so that you can shine
I was a musical theater kid that was a
total geek but I don't geek I mean that
in a very loving way yeah I love musical
theater
uh I am as well oh I feel bad now saying
that no I haven't been thinking about
loving way I swear so what I couldn't
get out of my head watching him uh dress
as Denny's you go there is the fact that
that is like just one step away from an
Elvis costume it's true and it kind of
reminded me of like you know those con
that constant footage of Elvis kind of
in that small concert setting with the
small stage and then I was like remember
when he was gonna play Elvis that's
where my head went the entire time oh
yeah but he was too big of a name to
play around that yeah
when they're putting that costume
together maybe a little bit of a look at
look at you I kind of want to know what
John Travolta has to think about that oh
I'm sure he loves it he probably does
love it it's pretty impressive yeah very
a really nice tribute too oh Harry the
new king of
you know